خاسرون ربما من هذا تقارب السوري التركيه
هل هناك طرف واحد ربما اكثر التشددا نحو
الاكراد التحديث
الاكبر كما ذكرته هي قوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه والاداره الذاتيه لاننا نعرف
ان همم تركيا وسوريا همم اضافه الى حتى
روسيا وايران هناك خلافات كثيره لكن قواسم
مشتركه على راس هذه القواسم المشتركه
ومصلحه المشتركه هي عدم استمرار الاداره
الذاتيه الكرديه طبعا كل الاسباب تركيا
لانهاء ما تعتبره تهديدا دائما على حدودها
من قبل همم القوات الكرديه همم دمشق همم
عدم تكريس واقع ان هناك اراد خارج السيطره
هو خاصه من اجل استعاده الثروات الاساسيه
في النفط والزراعه وموسكو بطبيعه الحال
لتعزيز وجهه نظرها وتعزيز سياستها نظام
تركيا الى هذا ما تعتبره التكتل في سوريا
اضافه الى موسكو طهران
ودمشق اضافه الى نقطه اجماع هي اجماع هذه
القوى الان على عدم استمرار الوجود
الامريكي في سوريا وضم تركيا الى هذا
الامر هذا ضربه للقوه الكرديه التي راهنت
وتراهن على استمرار دعم الامريكي لمواجهه
تركيا السابقان وسوريا الان يصبح تكاتل
اقليم خسر الاكبر هي القوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه الخاسر ايضا هم القوى السوريه
المعارضه سواء المسلحه او غير مسلحه في
المناطق الخاضعه بسيطره تركيا في الشمال
السوري او حتى منهم داخل تركيا لان هذا
تقارب سيستدعي اعاده نظر بكل التحالفات
القائمه الدعم التركي وهو هناك بوادر عن
انه بدا عمليا تراجع هذا الترتيبات او
تضيق على السوريين في تركيا ايش مثلا دفع
لاجئين للعوره لان هذا ملف اساسي ايضا في
التقارب من هنا الخاسب الاكبر يمكن حديث
عنه هو وسرديمقراطيه بدرجه الاولى
والمعارضه بشكل خاص المدعومه من انقره
اللاجئين كمان
ابرز ربما ملفات الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المرتقبه في يونيو المقبل في همم تركيا
نسال هنا عن الرابحين من هذا التقارب
وما اثر هما الطرفان الاساسيان في هذا
التقارب اي انقره والدماشق همم ادم نتحدث
عن التحدث عن مساله المهمه المشترك في ما
يتعلق والقاسم المشترك في ما يتعلق هو
سوريا الديمقراطيه
الصدر من اجواء ايجابيه على لسان كل من
شارك في اجتماع وزراء الدفاع في موسكو
التركي والسوري والروسي يتحدث عن ملفين
اساسيين التعاون في مساله التنسيق في
المحاربه تنظيمات الارهابيه بدون تحديدها
من وجهه نظر انقر الى الاكرار لكن ايضا
القوه الاخرى المصنفه ارهابيه في الشمال
السوري في الدب وغيرها وملف اللاجئين هناك
مصلحه لاردوغان لسحب هذه الورقه الضاغطه
من ايدي المعارضه التركيه قبل الانتخابات
في حزيران المقبل
وتسهيل عوده بشكل ما وهذا بالتعاون مع
دمشق كيف سيتم من خلال مصالحات هل ستستطيع
فعلا دمشق استقبال لاجئين هل يجبر هؤلاء
على العوده الوزير الخارجيه تحدث عن عوده
الطوعيه كل هذه
رهن الخطوات التي تحصل لكن هذا ملف اساسي
يكون في رصيد اردوغان في الانتخابات
المقبله بالنسبه لدمشق ايضا مساله
اللاجئين مهمه لسحب بها ورقه الضغط على
دمشق تستخدم همم ضد الذهب بما فيها كانت
من تركيا حتى الامس لكن ايضا من قوه اخرى
لكن هناك ايضا عناصر ربح اخرى التعبير همم
لصالح همم بالنسبه لسوريا اعاده همم
السيطر على المعابر مثلا امر مهم جدا على
صعيد التجاره لاعاده همم رفع الدعم تركيا
عن القوه التي تدعمها كانت ضد دمشق خلال
عشر سنوات هذا مهم اضافه للناحيه الرمزيه
للقولون ان سياسه اسقاط النظام
التركيه لم تنجح
بالضروره عن الخطوات الملموسه التي ربما
قد
تكون نتيجه لهذا ال همم اللقاء الاول من
نوعه 11 عام في البلدين يعني هل بدات تتضح
ملامح هذه الخطوات التي ستطبق على الارض
يعني حتى الان نحن امام واضح ان امام مسار
همم متماسك لاستعاده العلاقات والتدريج
اشاره اليها اردوغان في الايام الاخيره
بدا باللقاءات امنيه خرجت الى العالم
لاحقه تركيا السوريه ثم وزراء الدفاع
والان حديث عن اجتماع مرتق وزراء الخارجيه
تمهيدا للقاء محتمل بين الرئيسين اي
اردوغان والرئيس السوري الان ال- همم
عندما يجتمع وزراء الدفاع ومسؤول الاجهزه
الامنيه هذا يعني الحديث عن خطوات ميدانيه
عمليه وزراء الدفاتر تحدث عن الامور
ميدانيه يمكن التفكير بخطوات ستحصل ان همم
النجاح هذه الخطوات اي تقارب بكل الاحوال
منها مثلا مساله اعاده فتح طريق الذيقيه
حلب عوده المعابر همم مع تركيا الى سيطره
همم دمشق وما يعني ذلك من امكانيه فتح
طرقات الترانزيت من تركيا الى الخليج عبر
سوريا مثلا في مرحله لاحقه اعاده همم
ترتيبات والدعم مثل المجموعات في ادلب
واعاده كل نظر في كل همم يعني طبيعه الدعم
الذي يقدم
والتنظيم اعاده ترتيب هذا الامر والتسويات
التي يمكن ان تحصل سياسيا تمهيد لعمل
سياسي ومن سيقبل ومن سيربط الى مظ فاطمه
في شمال السوري مناهضه لهذا التقارب
وبالتالي نجاح لتقارب رهن هذه الخطوات لكن
واضح ايضا اننا امام همم
مسار تدريج للوصول الى مرحله تقارب على
اعلى المستويات طبعا موسكو تنظر بكثير من
الرضا الى هذا الامر على الارجح خاصه في
ظل ازمتها ايضا في اوكرانيا